this episode was made possible by a
cozia help make the world a greener
place by using the Eco Co search engine
to help plant trees all over the globe a
few years ago I worked in retail selling
cameras one of the first conversations I
had with the co worker was what if any
given number didn't exist how would that
change things would it ruin mathematics
in various fields of science the
consensus was it would really only
matter if that number were suddenly
banned after already existing in
calculations and measurements it
wouldn't really change anything if it
never existed because it wouldn't be
missing from the sequence numbers would
just proceed without it but there's
another number that actually didn't
exist for the longest time and when it
showed up it changed everything the
number zero has been a critical part of
mathematics for hundreds of years but it
didn't start out that way when the idea
of an absence of value became the number
zero it sparked enormous changes in the
mathematics of the time and it's
regarded as one of the most significant
breakthroughs in history think about how
we use zero in modern applications we
have what's called a positional number
system which means the location of a
digit is very important
the only real visual difference between
10 and 1 million is the position of the
number one if you add zeros after a
number it makes that number larger by
orders of magnitude if you add zeros
before the number it makes it smaller by
the same degree the idea of zero as a
placeholder allows for much greater
precision than was previously possible
as bizarre as it seems to us the people
of the past went thousands of years
without the number zero around 7,000
years ago the Sumerians used a system
that incorporated a placeholder symbol
or a blank space which indicated the
lack of a value so 501 would be written
five blank one or five symbol one the
interesting part about this system was
the symbol was never used at the end of
the number so the only way to
differentiate between five and 500 was
context the lack of a dedicated number
four zero complicated mathematics
tremendously and made even simple
computations incredibly tedious today it
seems like common sense to include a
number for nothing or for making numbers
larger or smaller so why did it take so
long for the idea of zero to catch on
strangely enough it wasn't a lack of
creativity that prevented the
implementation of the number zero
it was the stigma associated with the
idea of not
the ancient Greek thinker Parmenides was
of the opinion that nothing cannot exist
since to speak of something is to speak
of something that exists Europeans held
negative views about nothingness because
to the religious leaders of the time
everything that existed was because of
God and anything that did not exist must
be without God and therefore the work of
the devil to protect the people from the
evil works of zero its use was promptly
banned but merchants kept using it in
secret because it made tracking their
business much easier these negative
views on nothingness weren't always
present in other regions in some Eastern
societies such as in Buddhist groups the
idea of nothingness or emptiness is
actually a good thing and a critical
step on the road to Nirvana the first
known use of the number zero dates back
to India in the third or fourth century
written as part of what's known as the
bakkali manuscript its usage slowly
spread to other parts of the world and
more quickly to China and the Middle
East but it took a full thousand years
for the concept of zero to take hold in
Europe Fibonacci the Italian merchant
who played a critical role in bringing
the decimal system to Europe said the
method of the Indians surpasses any
known method to compute
it's a marvelous method they do their
computations using nine figures and the
symbol 0 when zero took its rightful
place among the other numbers it opened
multitudes of new possibilities it
drastically simplified calculations
allowed for the solving of more complex
equations it led to the work of the
Indian mathematician Brahma Gupta which
is often considered the beginning of
modern algebra then to the work of 9th
century Persian mathematician
al-khwarizmi which eventually made the
abacus obsolete and from whom we derived
the term algorithm as we saw earlier in
the video adding zeros provides greatly
improved precision which allowed later
thinkers like Isaac Newton to develop
calculus the study of continuous change
these three pillars of modern
mathematics algebra algorithms and
calculus all owe their existence to the
invention of a symbol to represent
nothing over the years zero would become
even more useful forming the basis for
electronics and computers allowing for
the notion of infinity and theoretical
mathematics the idea of a vacuum in
quantum physics and innumerable other
applications that we take for granted
today so the next time you're having a
bad day and think nothing matters you're
absolutely right the idea of zero allows
us to think bigger numbers like 30
million that's three followed by seven
zeroes and that's the number of trees it
cozia users have planted just by
browsing the
web cozia is a search engine that uses
its profits to plant trees just like
Google or Bing they make money from
search ads but the cool thing is they're
a nonprofit completely transparent what
they're spending and use their income to
fund reforestation projects around the
world this is such an amazing and
important project because they're not
selling a product they're just trying to
make the world a greener and better
place for future generations and we can
help they've made a legally binding
commitment to ensure that no profits can
ever be taken out of the company they
release a financial report every single
month to show where the money is going
and they respect your search privacy to
top things off a coziest servers run on
a hundred percent renewable energy and
they even operate their own solar plant
to power your searches thanks to the
trees a cozia has planted every search
removes a kg of co2 from the atmosphere
guys this project is amazing I use the
cozia it's completely free and you can
make a real difference for everyone if
you think that's as valuable as I do
start using the coziest search engine by
following the link below
[Music]